Speaker 1: Let's go to Henry
from Spokane, Washington.
Speaker 3: If you follow politics pretty well, I'd
say a little bit better than the average American.
I've never heard of Jamie Raskin. I was just
curious, like, how feasible it is for someone
who doesn't have a national appeal. And our
people don't know him nationally to actually
win the presidency. And like with different
moves that would take the. How possible is that?
Speaker 1: Yeah. I mean, if you ask ten people,
they'll give you ten different opinions. Lots of
people don't have a national presence until they
do. And sometimes running for president is what
what causes that? I mean, Sarah Palin was
virtually unknown. And by virtue of being selected
by John McCain, she became a household name. So
for me, Jamie, as I've said before, I like Jamie
Raskin is one possibility of someone I would
like if Joe Biden doesn't run for reelection.
One of the things about him that I think would
be a problem is a lot of people won't vote for
a Jewish guy. I think that the name recognition he
can overcome by becoming more well-known and that
could happen. But I think that he might be too
progressive for some voters. I think that Judaism
will be a problem for some people. So the name
recognition I'm not worried about, to be honest.
Speaker 3: Okay. Thank you.
Speaker 1: My pleasure. There's
Henry from Spokane with a very pithy and concise
question, which I'm glad I was able to answer